nascar  is investigating an apparent racist  message against the monster cup  series's only full-time black driver on  sunday a noose was found in bubba  wallace's team garage at a rainy  talladega speedway in alabama  the race yesterday was rained out by a  storm wallace made headlines two weeks  ago after nascar heeded his call to ban  the confederate flag at its events  today drivers are supporting wallace  i feel like he's taking a larger  uh standing and just wanting equality  and and  understandings i'm really proud and  we'll stand behind him 100  wallace called the incident a despicable  act of racism  today's rescheduled race at talladega  got started about 10 or so minutes ago  wallace is taking part